we have a voicemail number where you can
reach me at
uh 219 to david p i also am launching i
mentioned yesterday that we are new on
this platform called
bitclout you can find me there at
davidpakman.combitclout
what are going to be my top 20 holders
are going to have a system to directly
message me on the platform
and i will write you back so i'm
actually establishing a system if you
don't like the voicemail
if you don't like being like some of our
trolls leaving 10 12 voicemails a night
into the void
um follow me on bitcloud davidpakman.com
bitclout my top 20 coin holders
will have a function to directly direct
message me okay here is our friend
from argentina who lives in miami
unfortunately she has fallen
for an anti-vaccine talking point take a
listen
hi david this is another centennial from
miami right
this is something that i i'm worried
about
and i don't hear anybody talking about
um people who got vaccinated in this
december yes by june may not be
protected anymore because all
um they can guarantee is that
if the the protection lasted at least
six months
they suppose that maybe it will last
more but
they don't know and
i don't hear about any plan of how to
handle that
so two parts first of all you have to
understand something
when there was an announcement made that
said immunity lasts
for at least six months what they meant
was
we've been following people for six
months and so far
immunity hasn't declined then there was
a seventh month
and it looks like it's now seven months
what they mean by that is
the vaccines being relatively new all we
can say
is they work for the period of time that
people that we've been
putting in trials have been vaccinated
there is no reason to think
that after seven months or eight months
or nine months immunity will go down
the belief among epidemiologists and and
immunologists right now
is that immunity against those original
variants for which the original vaccines
were tuned
likely lasts at least years now if the
virus
changes then the effective the
efficacy will be diminished but by the
fall moderna and pfizer are expecting to
have
boosters tuned to the variant so when
the headline came out
only six months of immunity it was
widely used by anti-vax people to say it
only works for six months no what we
know is it's been six months
and there's no decline in immunity so
far and we'll look at it after seven and
we'll look at it after eight and we'll
look at it after nine okay that's all
that means
nothing to be worried about for the time
being we have a great bonus show for you
today
get instant access to the bonus show by
becoming a member
at joinpakman.com